today 300 newspapers coordinated
articles criticizing President Trump
just after he'd accused them of
coordinating articles criticizing
President Trump and nobody read them if
jerks like me weren't talking about it
would you even know yes another public
display of the press exercising their
right to irrelevance remember when the
New York Times ran an editorial saying
you should vote for Hillary and the rest
of the media followed
now they say Trump's blocking free
speech as they all screamed this in
unison Trump accuses them of groupthink
and they respond with groupthink now
since the election the media's been one
malfunctioning car alarm loud relentless
and broken this after sleeping through
Obama's terms ignoring Iran the DOJ the
IRS immigration while dreaming of
Hillary and now he's gone their dreams
are shattered and now they're wide awake
because Trump is their red bull what
phonies they gave Trump endless air time
while wringing their hands thinking it
was okay because Hillary had it in the
pantsuit but the palooka you propped up
wasn't the empty can you thought he was
while mocking Trump non-stop people
stopped caring about what you thought
that red bull gored your butt and now
all you can do is blame him
for what you helped do and they say
Trump targets all news not fake news
which is fake news they ignored the
clarifications that are obvious to us no
surprise remember when one of us would
criticize Obama or Hillary we'd be
called a bigot I remember that like it
was yesterday probably because it was
you sought to silence opinion through
fear and smear and now you pretend
you're the victim you're not oppressed
just depressed get over it
all right Jedidiah welcome back to the
show I know you were in Italy I heard
this wonderful place that was your
honeymoon was enough gelato for all of
us I don't see it anywhere Jedediah it
was delicious
fantastic so a lot oh but I made it back
it's a press speaking truth to power or
are they just whining to each other
they're so nauseating this is why people
can't stand the media it's like they say
oh we had to write this to remind people
of the important role that journalists
play if you have to write an editorial
to remind people of the important role
maybe you're doing something wrong there
might be a problem I just think it's so
funny because he he doesn't criticize
freedom of the press he's not attacking
freedom of the press he's it's packing
journalists who make it their job to
every day go out and with bated breath
wait for something to criticize about
him and it's not it's not about Donald
Trump
they've been doing this too they did it
to george w bush they did it to Dick
Cheney they did it to Sarah Palin the
problem is now they have a guy that
calls them out and they don't know what
to do about it and it's so crazy to me
that what you said before the
collectivist mentality he's out there
saying you guys are all against me you
guys are on a mission to take me out and
they in response are saying let's all
group together and collectively tell him
no we're important that's the point you
are making his point
thank you journalists again for making
his point and once again he's not I've
seen him pay homage to many journalists
he doesn't make us weep he's tired and
people out there are saying yeah you
know what he's tired of it he's speaking
out we wish other people before him
would have spoken out and when he says
stuff like the presses you know the
enemy and people are at home saying you
know what we've been waiting for someone
to call this out for so long thank you
for saying that it's not the press at
large but when you're out there saying
I'm an objective journalist and you're
not and you're making it your job every
day to take down the guy in the White
House somebody should call you out am i
thanking for doing that this is
ridiculous but I you know I mean to me
when he calls the American press enemy
of the American people thank you thank
you oh he never said it now and then how
he said
no he didn't here sweets I saw them yes
these eyes he said it he's beautiful
blue eyes the enemy of the American
people he is threatened even to change
the libel laws we've gone away from
briefings at the White House and you
know what I think it's appropriate for
the editorial sections of these
newspapers not the new sections it was
the editorials to say you know what
we're not the American of the American
people we are the American people the
American people in fact America is
founded on the idea of a free vigorous
press nobody's and that well hang on
drop this experiment purpose of the
press is to be an adversary to people in
power and hold them accountable
especially to a guy who lies and lies
and just so what's the big deal
yesterday in talking about John Brennan
revoking the security he says oh this
was all about protecting national
intelligence and then he turns around
tells the Wall Street Journal which
didn't run this editorial by the way the
Wall Street Journal tells him oh yeah
that was about the Russia investigation
because he's one of the guys that
started so somebody's got to be a
watchdog and called Trump on his lies
and yet you guys want a city like
Britain and they tell you the danger
this over half of Republicans listening
to this now say they agree with Trump oh
and guess what
okay it invites the threat this is what
one of the papers have invites the
threat of violence against people doing
their job which is to report the news
the violence against what you mean when
anti-shah went after that reporter Jesse
yes I am amazed that now we are
demanding that all of our politicians
tell the truth that's incredible to me
because there was all your health care
yeah and no one called him out on that
oh no I never heard position against
Barack Obama they loved Barack Obama
Obama joked about it the White House
Correspondents in her oh you guys are my
base and everybody laughed and was
drinking champagne stop pretending like
they were tough on Obama they weren't
they'd have a lot more credibility if
every administration that came around
they were this adversarial but they
don't and they're not that's the problem
because Donald Trump has a
them as dishonest Democrat party hats
let's give a medium right now are
extensions of the Democratic Party but
they give him no credit life or anything
good he does and deny him all credit for
anything he does that's everything is
framed as something he's done is evil is
wrong as backwards and he's not given a
fair shake so when he says we you guys
are the enemy of the people what he's
saying is you guys are denying the truth
to the American people you're feeding
them spin you're fitting them dishonest
propaganda to help the Democratic Party
you're not shooting straight well and
why they get that so upset is because
their credibility rests upon the fact
that they pretend to be independent and
when he says you're not independent and
you're lying about that they can't
handle it they can dish it out but they
can't take the only thing the king wants
is somebody who will adore him who will
honor him Donald what's the most
enchanting thing about this for a second
together America number one talk show in
America Rush Limbaugh so easy on Obama
number one newspaper in America Wall
Street Journal so easy on Obama number
one cable network in America Fox News so
easy everybody like get to the happy
place Dana I am convinced that when the
three hundred papers did this it reached
at least three hundred editors because I
swear no one would know about this if I
hadn't I'll be slightly contrarian oh no
you know I love the meeting I love news
I love journalism I feel like I'm adult
enough mature enough to be able to
identify when somebody at a certain
other network stands up and makes the
story about himself versus something
that is amazing like there's some great
journalism being done in Long formats at
in new formats like on podcast there's a
really good
that also a lot of it doesn't have
anything to do with President Trump
there's a lot of good stuff out there
and let a thousand flowers bloom the
First Amendment is includes the freedom
of the press for a reason I believe in
the Constitution I think our founding
fathers understood that as we've all
been saying the adversarial relationship
is going to be there but it is the most
important thing I don't mind if they did
the editorials it's fine it may be it
doesn't have that much of an effect
except for maybe to get us riled up but
also he has gone after the media it's
pretty viciously sometimes deservedly
but you know he likes to call himself a
counter-puncher well other people can be
counter punchers too and if they can
counter punch with an editorial so be it
Oh yep except that it was a counter
punch by mob they did it together and
they all sound the same he goes it just
makes him look better cuz he's lone and
I still maintain he's talking about fake
news not the whole news can we just run
what you wanted an example one of the
media and how they feel about Trump and
how they're in collusion with the
Democratic Party John Heilemann take it
away describe Trump I would like a
pollster to test this question how many
people in the Republican Party think
that it would be okay for Donald Trump
to dissolve their own grandparents I'm
virtually certain that if it was a
Donald Trump related question you get
like 10% that would be like Donald Trump
has the power to every once in cluding
kill my parents okay that's totally sane
Jedidiah
the thing is when the vast majority of
the media is opposed to one side on a
pretty consistent basis own it I feel
like they should own it when people who
are saying that their objective
journalists are repeatedly taking one
side over another that's a problem that
is the responsibility of any person with
a brain and a thinking person to come
out and say this is not a fair and
balanced media that doesn't mean there
aren't good journalists that doesn't
mean that journalists aren't supposed to
be watchdogs and that doesn't mean that
everyone in the press is terrible but
there is an inherent consistent
motivated agenda driven bias in much of
the media it's incumbent upon people to
call out a technology you have to admit
that no I don't any by the way the
example the minute
the example that Greg gave us of John
Heilemann John hung was not there as a
journalist he's there as a commentator
and he's offering his opinion in much
the way that we do at this table we have
never said anything like that
listen Obama would kill your parents at
the chair I won't tell you what we've
said on this network about Obama that's
not good quick did they have any balance
on that panel by the way this is not
what the editor was about the editorial
is about protecting the idea that
reporters can go out and do their job
report the news and they're not they're
not the enemy of the American pair that
was just one giant tantrum that's all it
was we've been calling Trump the enemy
of minorities of the Constitution of the
role of what he's for the last year and
a half so Trump that hits back and says
no you're the enemy of the American
people and they say Oh someone's gonna
all right enjoy